أدت القيود المخففة وموجة الحر
القياسية إلى إرسال حشود إلى الشواطئ في
كاليفورنيا في نهاية هذا الأسبوع ، أعادت العديد من المقاطعات
المحيطة بلوس أنجلوس فتح
شواطئها لإلقاء نظرة على تلك الصور ،
لكنهم ما زالوا يتأكدون من اتباع الأشخاص
لإرشادات التباعد الاجتماعي
.
يعيش Paul Vercammen في مقاطعة Ventura
بكاليفورنيا عندما تنظر إلى تلك الصور
التي أظهرناها للتو ، يبدو أنه
سيكون من الصعب جدًا تشجيع
الناس على الحصول على تباعد اجتماعي أكبر
بشكل جيد ، شيء واحد نجده على الرغم من أن
الكثير من الناس يريدون الشواطئ
للبقاء مفتوحين في مقاطعة فينتورا حيث
نحن الآن وفي مقاطعة أورانج ، لذا
فهم يستمعون إلى رجال الإنقاذ
ورجال الشرطة ينظرون خلفي
، لقد وضعوا بعض القواعد هنا ، لذا
فإن رمي الطبق الطائر للداخل
يكون بعيدًا اجتماعيًا ولكنك  لا يمكن جمع
مجموعة من الناس معًا
لبدء حفرة نار من هذا النوع من الأشياء التي
قد تكون خارج الحدود وفي التحدث إلى شخص ما
بعيدًا عن الكاميرا قبل ثانيتين ، كان
من مقاطعة لوس أنجلوس ، ذهب على
بعد أميال قليلة إلى هذه المقاطعة ورأى
أصدقاء لم يروهم منذ ستة أسابيع لكنهم
حافظوا على مسافة اجتماعية الآن
ما حدث في جميع أنحاء جنوب
كاليفورنيا في نهاية هذا الأسبوع خلال
اختبار الطقس الأول بعد
فريق kovat الليلي ، لديك
قواعد مختلفة في مقاطعات مختلفة ، لذا
في الجنوب منا فقط على بعد أميال في مقاطعة لوس أنجلوس ، لا
يمكنك أن تكون على الشاطئ بأي
شكل من الأشكال أو شكل
ضباط إنفاذ القانون في كل
مكان الآن هم ليسوا كذلك  السماح
بذلك ، ما نسمعه من السكان هو
أنهم يريدون توضيحًا لهذه القواعد
لأنك في مقاطعة أورانج
تظهر تلك الصور في نيوبورت بيتش ،
إنهم يستوعبون للغاية
ويقولون إن بإمكان الناس الذهاب إلى
الشاطئ فقط اتبع إرشادات التباعد الاجتماعي
ورأينا ملاحظة مفادها أن
الناس كانوا مهذبين ومهذبين
للغاية وردد رجال الإنقاذ صدى ذلك ،
لذا فهي قصة ساخنة تتكشف هنا في
كاليفورنيا.  تحاول جميع هذه
المقاطعات المختلفة معرفة ما
يجب فعله أثناء موجة الحر ولكن كما قلت
، نرى أشخاصًا يتصرفون
ويلتزمون بإرشادات التباعد الاجتماعي ،